Our next guest has his comedy
special, "Nori,"
available now on Spotify.
Please welcome the very funny
Nore Davis.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey. What's up?
Thank you, thank you. Alright.
Let's do this before it's
my bedtime 'cause I'm tired.
[ Laughter ]
When you in 30
and after 10:00 p.m.,
your body's in low-power mode.
It's something like I grew
this janitor in me.
He's like, "Oh, these lights
should be off."
"But wait, I'm driving."
[ Laughter ]
"That's too much electricity,
young man.
You should be in bed.
That is too much.
Too much."
But only thing that really
keeps me up
is, like, I love watching
my movie franchise.
"Jurassic Park,"
I love those films.
[ Crowd cheers ]
Yeah. Yeah.
'Cause it really makes white
people believe dinosaurs
would've been their pets.
[ Laughter ]
They hit them with that
Chris Pratt palm,
"hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, Blue.
Hey, you know me."
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, hey."
It's like reptiles don't listen.
[ Laughter ]
I've never seen a white person
walking a Komodo dragon.
[ Laughter ]
But it's like, "Hey, hey, hey,
hey. You know me."
And the raptor stops, like,
"Oh, you lucky
I love 'Parks and Recreation.'"
[ Laughter ]
"You lucky. I'll see you later,
Star-Lord."
[ Laughter ]
He comes back.
Capitalism gonna cap, baby.
But, like, how long are we going
to keep doing this hierarchy?
Working class, poor,
rich, wealthy.
It's like a game,
but it's our real lives.
The wealthy and rich
are playing Monopoly.
Working class and poor,
we're playing Trouble.
[ Laughter ]
Pop, pop! $6?
That's all I can do today.
Pop, pop! Two?
I can't even leave the house.
[ Laughter ]
I got to wait for a six.
It's like the wealthy,
they have the money.
Just print the money.
[ Laughter ]
You have it.
Just, like, command P.
It's always been that.
[ Laughter ]
It never changed,
no matter how old you are.
But, you know, I'm not
a politician.
I'm just an Aries.
That's all I know.
[ Laughter ]
I'm always trying to get rid of
generational trauma
within my family, you know,
because I'm a millennial,
and I was raised
by baby boomer parents.
And you know that
we was their property.
You know that saying, "I brought
you in this world,
I'll take you out"?
[ Laughter ]
What makes you think
that's a good investment?
[ Laughter ]
You can always tell millennials
have trauma from their parents
'cause when they talk to
their friends,
they call them
by their first name.
"Hey, how's your mom?"
"Who, Jackie?"
[ Laughter ]
"She alright. Still judging."
They have so much trauma,
but I give them grace
because, you know, therapy just
came out in 2020.
They missed it.
[ Laughter ]
It just came out.
It's so hard.
Like, you ever tell
a baby boomer you love them?
"I love you."
They start malfunctioning.
[ Laughter ]
"Love?"
It was my dad's birthday
the other day.
I was like,
"Hey, Dad, happy birthday."
He was like, "Alright."
[ Laughter ]
"Alright"? Not even like
a cool "Alright!"
It was like a prisoner telling
the guard, like,
"Hey, happy birthday."
"Alright, alright.
Back in your cell.
Back in there."
So that's why I always do,
like, an outward
love expression
towards my child.
Like, he's generation alpha.
And, you know, so with
a millennial,
they are not our property.
They are content.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. "Get to work!"
"Dad, I'm hungry."
"You go viral, you eat!"
[ Laughter ]
"When you go viral, you'll eat.
Come on, let's go."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm Nore Davis.
Thank you so much!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, hey, hey.
-Nore Davis.
"Nori" is available on Spotify.
We'll be right back, everybody.